buongiorno bentornati a una nuova
puntata del blog ma in realtà oggi mi
sono svegliato tardissimo stanno per
arrivare
gianmarco errico a casa mia perché
abbiamo pensato di fare una cosa che
volevo fare un sacco di tempo
le persone solitamente si affidano a dei
professionisti del settore per fare
questa cosa in particolare io
personalmente però amo il file atente
cose fatte male però che hanno
personalità cuore carisma detto ciò
voglio provare a fare un filtro
instagram ancora non ha idea di come si
facciano i filtri instagram né di di
cosa fare è però mi piaceva l'idea di
avere un qualcosa che fosse una sorta di
regalo natalizio semplice non so nemmeno
quanto ci vorrà per farlo approvare
credo che ci voglia un po di tempo
quindi incrociamo le dita milano che
cosa succede
detto ciò volevo anche per vedere un
acquisto pazzesco che ho fatto su
internet questa qui che sembra una gonna
in realtà è il mio nuovo pigiama la casa
è una cosa di commessa giapponese non so
se si vede ecco ora si vede quindi oggi
andrò in giro e sembrerò a metà tra un
samurai è un tipo uno sciamano 1 shamu
rai tempo ma sempre la mer bene una cosa
assurda dei blog ma se che alla fine di
ogni anno almeno dell'anno scorso
scusate tanto io mi preparo non so se lo
vedete unite alla fine di ogni anno alla
fine di ogni anno arrivi stremato perché
comunque girare ogni giorni non è che
sia proprio una persona più costante del
mondo girarli e montarli insieme eri già
mi tutti quanti è abbastanza intensiva
come cosa fotografi ne dici l'anno
prossimo non lo farò mai più manco se mi
pagano
eppure mi mancavano sarò sincero e devo
dire che ha energie al momento ci ci
siamo vediamo andando
che cosa succederà vi prego mostrato
sostegno sostenete se niente il tempo
sempre bello hanno fatto i fatti sono
fatti
mamma mia il macello io vorrei fare
solamente grazie a cucina adottata i
pacchi di farine di zucchero che si sono
accumulati dentro lo uso come tiene
tutti in via tedesca di loro è stato a
grandi ragazzi
guardandola degli anni stato ria per
capire come fare a fare i filtri provare
cosa ho scoperto che serve un programma
si chiama spark a r credo sia gratis e
credo però che servano laurea per
utilizzarlo perché qua tutti dicono è
facilissimo ma poi stanno lì anche nelle
cose in computer grafica
ma quel signore degli anelli signorelli
in frode in faccia dal pci ai non tutti
i filtri vanno bene per instagram
perché se sono troppo pesanti non li
carica su instagram sono tipo qui video
nei quali impari una cosa meno di 24 ore
[Musica]
ma non è capito che in questo inizio
aspettare per far vendere vendere
vendere vendere un bene
[Applauso]
all serie a tim io non ho preparato
niente manco fin del 3 andiamo a
ripassare andiamo a ripassare veloce
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi ma so che apprezzerà che
maggiormente ma tu sei il santa clara
che importavano solo guarda questa
giapponese
esatto
stavo studiando per il filtro non sono
sveglio da meno di mezz'ora lo giuro è
molto difficile ragazzi non è
facilissimo fortunatamente sei mani
pezzi me bisogna farsi venire un'idea
capito per cui le persone vorrebbero
combattere falsi stampati scanu si una
cosa che divertente la prima mangiamo
che secondario questa cosa a te possiamo
far veder educazione di questo cane qui
contino legata la pappa 3 2 1 sirigu che
cosa abbiamo
non so come si chiamano non so come si
chiama la luganese chiamano cascini
questi conosciamo e non so come si
chiamano ragazzi c'è una quantità di
plastica impressionante
però c'è anche una quantità di bontà
punto che stai facendo con quelli in
bocca un po lei non sta rompendo no no
no
ah che bella di guida il pool basta
vabbè fa qualcosa dal provvedo subito
come abbiamo denunciato questo qui è
perché sapevo che avrebbe portato il
giapponese ovviamente ho pensato di dare
capito un tocco un pochino già mangia la
plastica furbo allora che vogliamo fare
per favore ad uno molto attiva
i miei 10 netiq non credo di essere
all'altezza però ci proviamo
pensavo pensavo di fare qualcosa che c'è
in faccia
senape filtro è no perché vuoi anche
fare un qualcosa che attaccato un
qualcosa che ti esce fuori dagli occhi
non sei l'aiuto nel divisa pensando se
facessimo qualcosa che ha trattato in
faccia
idea geniale perché poi fai prima cosa
che attacca un raro tipo
allora io ho avuto una grande idea è
orribile non ripi nacho messo sette ore
per far venire lì la mia faccia e non
quella di jamila mister jimmy laden e
aladdin sembrano più digitate la disney
che questo è
capire però che la disney ha tante
persone che rappresentano nere questo è
un nero forse la sirenetta jazmin grace
imola principessa e il ranocchio all in
alla 52 riferisco ha sfruttato questo
milan oppure tipo e cesira le penne non
hai davanti questo che potrebbe essere
percepito come sgradevole in realtà non
voleva esserlo allora vediamo la balena
di pinocchio che c'è questo scott hicks
qui più lacrime non comunque guarda che
la vita era ottimo se io per quello
abdillah mantilla segreta e poi c'erano
barilla procedere un balocco e nonno
diciamola era bellissima questa è una
maschera che presenta è stata messa al
fine di hai capito io direi che a posto
abbiamo tolto il filtro per novo allora
senti contrasti per strada ti giuro
cambierei il marciapiede sebbene foto e
sherlock sonar bath shower bankside
beckham pato è veramente identico lo sai
pure col capello in corso a mito gli
difetti venire lo stesso perché non ha
difetti e mangiati saresti the us
aretina tua faccia così più facile e
vero io che sono pieno di difetti si
vede la l'opzione di prendere o maschio
o femmina e abbiamo scelto donna perché
comunque avendo un sacco di ragazze che
ci seguono e giusto persone per femmine
in questo modo noi avremo una ragazza
facciamo delle lenti geni a chi non
piacciono le origini in oro niente erano
faceva niente racz è il filtro e aprile
casting ma perché mi di rovinare la
giornata guarda fai il tuo agio non ti
piacciono le donne da guarda in faccia
non mi interessa
ti prendeva un neon
per forza ok mazzetti stai facendo come
è possibile ci piacciono dai ci stanno
lentiggini la possiamo fare rossa questa
ragazza no ho i capelli rossi o non
cilia e le lenti marling che non sa
cos'è un filtro non sono sei ma ma scusa
ma o ai lentiggini concederai vabbè ti
fai comparire le lentiggini come di fi
comparire i capelli rossi tipo reggina
il ghiaccio mi sto convincendo fine con
7 cosmogirl cosmo con una ragazza
truccata di universo una ragazza che
l'universo sul viso a me non piace
immaginavo e le mettiamo con un rossetto
viola viola bravo ti piace meno male che
dovesse delicato ho capito un secondo se
non lo so destra col formaggio rate non
è che il mi convinca tanto pago questo è
il filtro di martina martina pinto
trasmissione di appena salvata che cosa
solo al kobe all in one fumo agli occhi
escono gli occhi mi sembra una mezza
letto quest'anno non si appella è solo
abbiamo quello di luigi e.coli ha un pò
guardà come cambierà il volto il lume
rang ok questo è già un po più stiloso
se non siete parte così il traguardo di
la pelle c'è diventi lucido e
raccapricciante però aspetta se togli
ovviamente la faccia sotto ti rimane
solo quello che sta sopra da una roba
misteriosa questa donna cosmica cosmica
un piccolo pc cambia faccia questa cosa
oddio madonna sembra che sia stato
costante
a me sta meglio a me lo sai
mammamia rega
io non capisco mi sa che non siamo in
grado di creare un filtro minonna
seconda chance
ok così è vero sembra un clown
ho preso a pugni sui ricordi molto joker
all'inizio del film delle prime erano
tutti proprio che garantito alcun
messaggio
uno che andava a tema vorrei seguire
l'idea di gianmarco e quindi creare una
specie di faccia simile a quella di un
bulldog francese come lo chiamiamo cosmo
torio cosmo dog fermo per guarde un bel
2 rec dormendo in piedi questo modello
mi prende in giro questo questa cosa
terza con di cira class 20 20 cioè il
web
mi sembrano farci uscire rispondere i
modi ma mirko troppo paradosso
scriveremo nei commenti palazzi lo
faremo su instagram però lo devi fare
con il volto di cosmo ok vedi che lo
abbassate un pochino ancora così vanno
troppo giù gudo non ha il naso
chiaramente ma davanti tutto il resto
homer simpson è giusto che hanno volta
le donne morte c'era qualcosa di un del
city ovviamente quella parte del naso
non è convincente a perché resto invece
cos'è
ma da tutta questa roba qua corda pure
quello che i pirati dei caraibi signor
polipo sì ma che cos'è c'è la green
troviamo le competenze per fare un aero
padre dtc e la copia brutta di volte ma
non ragazzi e li porti comunque sempre
share lo guardavano per farlo sto per
farlo sto per farlo aspetta aspetta
no no
e disperato economia e accaduto poco mi
ricorda qualcuno lo sai è vero ma
ricordo qualcuno che esiste purtroppo il
gioco delle somiglianze facciamo
chi sono enrico nel cosmo
ce la facciamo avere su instagram
vogliamo di vederla
vai te l'ultima volta essendo un filtro
femminile sarei curioso di vederlo su
una donna con filtro piacente quindi con
questi occhi un po più grandi perché
cosmo caorle agli occhi grandi no si
deve rispetto al mare ecco finire che
comunque tra tutte le cose che abbiamo
fatto cose ma pure la più bella
pensa un po ma è conveniente staccava la
mia faccia
forse ho capito com'è bello cosmogirl
cioè al buio spegne la luce ha quindi
che se vede un non so che di video però
è vero cosmo ma è diverso tra smith
questa giornata dice addio perché sto
qui va beh sì e natalizio ragazzi in
questo modo natalizio volevo dirvi che
questa giornata di chamber l'abbiamo
passata nel cercare di fare un filtro
che non è venuto ma che credo dovrebbero
apprezzare tutti quanti e cosmo credo
che sono due filtri fatemi sapere se no
va bene li metto fuori
no è negativa di appare in un sondaggio
si o no i 106 milioni hanno diranno sì
però ci stai ci sta non solo perché
tutti vogliamo essere una a domani con
una nuova puntata ciao